à dublin en irlande le coup d'envoi du
tour de france avec le prologue remporté
sylviane instant par le britannique
chris boardman en marge du tour cette
affaire d'anabolisants 400 flacons
retrouvé en possession du soigneur de
richard virenque la veillée d'armes pour
les tricolores à clairefontaine le rêve
bleu de tout un pays qui se prépare à
vivre cet événement historique
une émotion collective à la hauteur de
l'enjeu les départs en vacances beaucoup
de monde sur les routes va km de
bouchons dans la vallée du rhône
circulation très dense sur la route du
soleil
à berlin un million de jeunes pour
assister à la grande fête de techno la
love parade de cortège et des millions
de décibels pour cette manifestation
placée sous le signe de l'amour et de la
paix festival d'avignon avec pour la
première fois depuis gérard philipe une
nouvelle interprétation du cid c'est un
jeune comédien noir qui reprend le rôle
madame monsieur bonsoir ce samedi
marquée par une actualité sportive
extrêmement riche
bien évidemment la finale du mondial
dans tous les esprits nous y reviendrons
dans un instant mais d'abord cette
affaire qui se déroule en marge du tour
de france et qui a suscité tout au long
de la journée une certaine émotion à
soigneur de l'équipe festina été arrêté
à la frontière franco-belge en sa
possession 400 flacons de produits
dopants tout genre celui qui n'est autre
que le soigneur personnel de richard
virenque a été interpellé mercredi et
présenté au parquet l'idylle derrière
alexandre kara nathalie gallet à
l'entraînement en apparence rien ne
reflète le malaise est pourtant pour
l'équipe festina l'une des favorites le
tour commence bien mal depuis hier sur
le tour un seul mot est sur toutes les
lèvres dopage avant tempête qui vient de
la frontière belge où l'un des soigneurs
de l'équipe a été arrêté en possession
d'une importante quantité de produits
interdits
et bien sûr il ya vote rénové ça me
confirme surtout il faut être très
déterminé dans la lutte entre les
pourvoyeurs de ses produits dopants qui
amène ses produits dopants vers les
sportifs c'est mercredi midi que vit les
voûtes ma soeur de festina de
nationalité belge a été arrêté dans sa
voiture les douaniers ont découvert des
centaines de gélules d'anabolisants
ainsi que de le payer un produit qui
favorise l'oxygénation du sang
le masseur de l'équipe festina était
présenté au parquet et mis en examen
probablement pour infraction à la
législation sur les stupéfiants
à la suite de cette interpellation les
enquêteurs ont effectué jeudi soir une
perquisition au siège français de
festina près de lyon sur place les
policiers auraient découvert d'autres
produits suspects à dublin le directeur
sportif de festina a déclaré avoir
appris cette affaire par la presse
pour lui il ne peut pas y avoir de
conséquence directe pour son équipe
je crois qu'on rendant dans la science
fiction on peut pas je veux dire
interpeller les gens qui ont a priori
rien à voir avec cette affaire est bon
je crois que le mieux c'est que chacun
puisse faire son travail et la justice
et nous mêmes sur ce tour de france et
la cour ce matin
pardon pour jean marie leblanc le
directeur du tour annoncé qu'il
attendrait les conclusions de la justice
pour réagir
tout en excluant l'éventualité d'une
sanction collective
il n'est pas envisageable pour une
action frauduleuse peut être isolé qui
c'est de priver
toute une équipe et surtout des coureurs
d'une participation au tour de france
cette affaire est de toute façon un coup
dur pour l'équipe festina qui compte
dans ses rangs trois des favoris du tour
alex joue le richard virenque et laurent
dufaux pour leur part les dirigeants
d'equipe pourrait être entendu par les
enquêteurs dès leur retour en france
mardi prochain
et puis marie george buffet décidé
aujourd'hui de suspendre pendant un an
le judoka djamel bouras pour dopage
la fédération s'était déclarée
incompétente c'est donc la ministre de
la jeunesse et des sports qui a appliqué
la loi
retour à dublin en irlande départ cet
après-midi du prologue du tour de france
5 km 600 de contre la montre à travers
les rues de la ville en ouverture de
cette 85e édition de la grande boucle
c'est le français denis leproux qui a
été le premier à prendre le départ et
c'est le britannique chris boardman qui
a remporté ce prologue françois brabant
vu d'en haut à dublin le temps à l'air
typiquement britannique ça tombe bien
voilà sujets de sa gracieuse majesté
chris boardman c'est le favori du
prologue recordman de l'heure en titre
spécialiste du contre la montre
l'anglais a toutes les qualités pour
s'imposer sur ce parcours très plat dans
le centre de la capitale irlandaise
et en plus la route est sèche boardman
couvre les 5 km 600 en six minutes 12
secondes 36 centièmes dans ce prologue
on attendait aussi devoir jan ullrich
l'allemand depuis sa victoire dans le
tour de l'an dernier n'a pas montré
grand chose on l'a dit mal préparés voir
un peu enrobé mais ulrich ses pédales et
contre le chrono et défendre maillot
jaune ça motive
il termine 4ème et les français pas de
quoi faire la fine bouche
laurent jalabert tout nouveau champion
de france prend une très belle troisième
place à égalité de temps avec ulrich
quant à richard virenque dans une
spécialité qui n'est vraiment pas la
sienne il a limité les dégâts mais il
n'est pas dans les dix premiers le
nouveau leader ou au tour de france
comme prévu s'appelle donc chris
boardman sur le tour le vainqueur a
forcément un maillot jaune sur le dos
sur le tour seulement la ville de dublin
s'était parée des couleurs de la france
pour accueillir le tour qui fait figure
d'événement les yeux grands ouverts les
habitants regardait le long des rues
passée l'étape l'ambiance avant et
pendant la course étienne l'énarque pour
cette journée historique l'irlande
s'était donc mis sur son 31 dans les
bureaux de cette compagnie d'assurance
qui surplombe le passage du prologue
tous les salariés ont été invités à
applaudir 189 x donc ils ont hurlé à
chaque passage d'un coureur du tour de
france avec toutes ces fenêtres qui
donnent sur la rue on s'est dit que
c'était vraiment trop bête que c'était
une grande chance de permettre aux
salariés de venir voir le tour sur leur
lieu de travail
on l'a dit et répété pour les irlandais
ce tour est une grande première
prenez les gendarmes locaux par exemple
ils ont dû intégrer la méthode de nos
motards à nous alignement des engins
exigé et communication par moments
difficiles ils choisissent une ligne et
puis ils changent ils en prennent une
autre on ferait sans doute la même chose
et puis leur expliquer
le problème c'est que je ne ferais pas
très bien anglais alors avec la tête
dans les nuages des dizaines de milliers
de dubly noah se sont donc familiariser
avec le tour et sa caravane publicitaire
sur laquelle les jugements sont
d'ailleurs assez partagés
la caravane publicitaire c'est vraiment
un grand grand spectacle vous préférez
la caravane où les coureurs non la
caravane et dans cette foule qui n'avait
d'yeux que pour les coureurs du tour
une exception la communauté française en
vacances à dublin était telle coupe du
monde oblige beaucoup plus football que
vélo cannes irlandais intrépide existe
sous leurs yeux le maillot du brésil et
les voilà qu'ils sortaient leurs griffes
il y avait pour certains aujourd'hui à
dublin d'autres priorités que le tour de
france
j'en viens maintenant à cette dernière
journée avant la finale du mondial une
journée de répétition stade de france
voici ce que vous entendrez demain soir
pour la première fois dans l'histoire de
la coupe du monde
les hymnes nationaux français et
brésiliens seront chantées avant le coup
d'envoi
accompagné par la garde républicaine le
choeur de l'armée française tout un
encouragement à l'équipe des tricolores
christophe tortora roger motte demain
peu avant 21h les choeurs de l'armée
française et la musique de la garde
républicaine en entrant sur la pelouse
du stade de france seront au centre du
monde sans gendarme heureux d'avoir à
chanter pour la première fois de
l'histoire de la coupe les hymnes
nationaux particulièrement fier d'avoir
a interprété la marseillaise
une aide pour didier deschamps et pour
ses hommes
on peut imaginer que lorsque nous allons
chanter la marseillaise les 80000
personnes autour de nous pour chanter en
même temps peut-être 70000 personnes six
à dix mille brésilien en tout état de
cause ça fait je crois que ce sera la
plus grande chorale que je n'ai jamais
dirigé
ce matin l'hymne brésilien a bien sûr
également été interprété les gendarmes
l'affirment ils chanteront les deux
hymnes avec le même enthousiasme
mais une fois dans les tribunes les
choeurs de l'armée française ne battront
plus que pour une équipe celle des bleus
et pendant ce temps là la veillée
d'armes pour l'équipe de france à
clairefontaine aimé jacquet a annoncé
qu'il se retirait quoi qu'il arrive
après la coupe du monde même dans
l'euphorie de la victoire il ne
reviendra pas sur sa décision
dernière heure pour les tricolores donc
elle la france se prépare à cet immense
émotion collective
le rêve bleu yann lavoix andré germain
les chambres du château de
clairefontaine retiendront à jamais les
rêves des vingt-deux français cette nuit
comme tous les enfants ils ont imaginé
un jour gagner la finale de la coupe du
monde lorsqu'il est un drap la lumière
thuram rêvera peut-être cette pluie de
ce temps passé mais inoubliable jouer
dans le bac à sable en bas de mon
immeuble et puis on se disait tiens on
joue la finale celui qui gagne la gagner
la finale de la coupe du monde
et puis à chaque fois il y en avait un
qui voulait recommencer parce qu'il
avait perdu démarrant ça c'est pour la
fosse on recommence j'espère que
dimanche je ne demanderai pas
recommencer les quartz et demain les
lions le rêve devient réalité
passons maintenant dans la chambre
voisine il ya là un rêveur qui croient à
la prémonition
ça me rappelle un peu le rêve j'avais
fait ya quelques années en disant que la
france accueille la coupe du monde en 98
et en finale contre le brésil elle a
gagné 2 0 pour sk qui ne l'étape dans ce
rêve il ya des coïncidences dans la vie
qui laisse songeur
jacquet lui n'a pas beaucoup dormi
depuis le début de la coupe du monde
pragmatique il a surtout travaillé bien
plus qu'il n'a rêvé où j'ai pas
tellement rêver à la finale
je pensais surtout à ce que à nos matchs
à notre progression
mais c'est vrai que inconsciemment on y
pense
la seule chose enfin qui me venait à
l'esprit c'est que la france soit en
finale le reste l'adversaire
à mon avis était secondaire il est
encore temps de fantasmer et d'espérer
oui il est permis de rêver cette nuit
pourvu que demain tous ses rêves
deviennent réalité
ils rejoignent en direct à
clairefontaine mienne la voix c'était
donc le dernier entraînement ce soir à
huis clos pour les bleus at on déjà une
idée sur la composition de l'équipe qui
affrontera demain le brésil aimé jacquet
nous a dit ce matin il y aura des
changements et lors du dernier
entraînement que lui aux alentours de 18
auteur tout à l'heure les 22 joueurs
étaient opérationnels le dr ferret les a
remis dans les mains d'aimé jacquet
disant tu n'as plus qu'à choisir
on sait qu'il va donc avoir des
changements on connaît le changement
avec laurent blanc qui va être remplacé
par franck leboeuf puisque laurent blanc
sera suspendu on sait aussi que 42 une
cheville un peu endolori et il pourrait
bien être absent de cette grande finale
il serait ce moment là sans doute
remplacé par boghossian car je pense que
le milieu de terrain sera assez fourni
pour contrer au maximum les joueurs
brésiliens donc sinon pour ce qui est de
l'équipe
vraiment on ne la connaîtra logiquement
nous que une heure avant le match les
joueurs eux la connaîtrons aux alentours
du déjeuner après une légère causerie
aimé jacquet fournir à l'équipe type à
ses propres joueurs
ensuite et bien vers 17 18 heures les
joueurs quitteront clairefontaine par le
portail que vous êtes vous seriez censé
voir mais comme vous pouvez le voir je
ne suis pas tout seul
et ici en attend terriblement l'équipe
de france et les gens vont rester la
tête une partie de la nuit et demain ils
seront environ 500 pour encourager
l'équipe de france voyez il ya de
l'ambiance ici déjà l'équipe brésilienne
n'a lésiné à fut-elle sa stratégie peu
de choses ont filtré aujourd'hui une
journée à huit clos sauf pour la presse
brésilienne qui a eu le droit de suivre
le dernier entraînement laurent frédéric
bollée frédéric basket lésigny seine et
marne france peut-être brésil car c'est
là que la seleçao a élu domicile
un hôtel en forme de château à moins que
ce ne soit l'inversé un camp retranché
surtout à la veille d'une finale de
coupe du monde les brésiliens qui ont
instauré le semis huit clos pour leurs
entraînements de l'après midi seuls les
journalistes brésiliens seront autorisés
à y assister
en attendant on envoie ses derniers
papiers et pour s'occuper
on fait même une photo souvenir les
brésiliens sont plutôt de bonne humeur
16h30 l'entraînement va bientôt
commencer c'est l'heure du filtrage rien
à faire les médias français nous
n'entrerons pas alors pour avoir des
nouvelles pas d'autre solution que
d'attendre le retour des confrères sud
américain et là on apprend que le brésil
songe aux penaltys
chose plus elle confesse les tirs au but
de penser toujours et on peut arriver
notre décision est une autre finale de
coupe du monde les brésiliens qui ont
intérêt à mettre toutes les chances de
leur côté à lésigny l'église leur est
ouverte à toute heure et monsieur le
curé a même fait récemment une rencontre
surprenante préparer les penalties c'est
bien mais il ya aussi les prières et
j'ai vu dunga donc la capitaine de
l'équipe brésilienne qui étaient là en
prière j'allais préparer les mises et
puis bon ben je suis tombé sur un
carburant
et monsieur le curé de penser que demain
peut-être dieu reconnaîtra les siens et
ne rejoignent maintenant à lésigny
laurent frédéric bollée évidemment la
question que tout le monde se pose c'est
la condition physique de la star
brésilienne ronaldo
voilà alors effectivement cet après midi
il y avait un entraînement à ce huis
clos si l'on ose dire béatrice comme
vous l'avez compris alors on a
évidemment questionner nos confrères sur
ronaldo qu'at-il fait cet après midi il
a couru pas beaucoup car il faut dire
c'était un entraînement assez
décontracté on a même vu le gardien de
but taffarel du brésil joué comme un
joueur normal il sait pas du tout
entraîné dans les buts alors ronaldo
aura donc un petit peu couru sans plus
alors qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut
dire que c'est normal qu'ils soient
fatigués nous ont dit nos confrères ça
fait deux ans qu'il joue pratiquement
toutes les semaines un match tous les
trois jours c'est normal qu'il soit
fatigué cette coupe du monde et apporte
du stress aussi donc c'est normal que
ronaldo s'en ressentent mais il va bien
sûr jouer il ne saurait pas être
question de l'absence de ronaldo et nos
amis brésiliens et bien pense que même
un ronaldo diminué est capable de battre
à lui tout seul
l'équipe de france merci à laurent
frédéric bollée quatre fois championne
du monde l'équipe brésilienne sera
soutenu par la ferveur légendaire du
pays tout entier 160 millions de joueurs
et d'entraîneurs potentiels au brésil le
football est plus qu'une passion dans
les favelas de rio par exemple le
football et la religion portrait d'un de
ses habitants des quartiers pauvres
balocchi et christophe du cir en france
vaillant
c'est beau comme un décor de carte
postale c'est une plage des beaux
quartiers à côté de copacabana
tout le monde peut venir ici et vidéo le
carioca ne s'en prive pas il porte un
maillot du paris saint-germain qu'un ami
lui rapporter de france
ils doivent le football et la mer il
habite juste à côté de la plage mais
mido vit dans un autre monde
il lui depuis toujours dans une favela
accrochées aux collines juste au-dessus
dé vos cartes vidéo est un privilégié
il a un travail à la préfecture de rio
300 dollars par mois
c'est assez pour vivre dans la favela
c'est bien trop peu pour habiter en
ville de chez lui il a une vue
imprenable sur le christ du corcovado
bien prenable sur la mer entre deux
immeubles et une vue imprenable sur
chape et aux ventes vieira et ses
habitants ici il ya l'eau courante et
l'électricité et un taux de chômage
record comme dans toutes les femmes elle
ici je suis tranquille je me sens à
l'aise c'est pas le paradis c'est un
endroit où peu de gens aimeraient vivre
mais moi je nous sens bien tout en
bitume
si le terrain de foot de la favela où
l'on joue pieds nus quand on n'a pas les
moyens et avec des choses dures quand on
peut cp comme spectateur et la vidéo et
les policiers qui jour et nuit montent
la garde devant la favela france brésil
la finale de la coupe du monde ici tout
le monde ne pense qu'à ça et pour gagner
les brésiliens comptent sur le 12e homme
providentiel entendu de dieu est
importante
c'est quelque chose qui coule moins dix
ans il est possible que le résultat
dépend de la volonté des religieuses et
vous savez la technique toujours la
technique
moi je vais prier pour que le brésil
gagne la coupe avec 1100 prière le
brésil va gagner les brésilens pirlo que
dieu aidez chez eux à bahia au brésil
on dit que le football est presque aussi
important que la religion il suffit de
voir les joueurs de la sélection
nationale et ce signe après un but ou
une victoire pour remercier le tout
puissant
chaque jour de la semaine suivante
précise le frère bruno résume la messe à
notre-dame de rosario à deux pas de la
favela me donnait pas plus croyants des
brésiliens quant au frère bruno
il a vécu dix ans en france la france le
brésil la coupe du monde
et dieu dans tout ça allez vous priez
pour le brésil non je prie pour brésil
pour d'autres occasions dans ce motif ne
souhaite pas pour pour mort
drôle de pays en vérité le pays du
football et des prières le pays des
coupes du monde du luxe et de la misère
le pays de mido qui se des favelas le
carioca de chapet sommes en guerre la
surprise de ce mondial aura été sans
conteste l'engouement des femmes
françaises en les disait anti foot et
pourtant elles se sont convertis au
point de devenir de véritables
supporteurs à l'image de ces femmes
d'amérique du sud ou du nord de l'europe
christelle bertrand dominique merlet en
france les femmes il football n'ont
jamais fait bon ménage
le mondial a donné un bon coup de balai
aux idées reçues trois mois avant le
premier match
70 % n'en n'avez rien à faire mais la
france gagne alors un gradin comme un
ministre ça peut être aussi fini
est indifférente en fait aux sports en
tant que tel mais finalement elle
n'était pas indifférente à l'événement
mondial spectaculaire à l'intensité
émotionnelle et dramatique qui est en
train de se jouer et qu'on est en train
de vivre la coupe du monde c'est la
grande saga de l'été le casting le
scénario tout est là pour faire un
succès des rebondissements des épisodes
français ont été suivis à 50% par des
femmes même s'en va voir sa vie viseur
j'ai vibré quand même ce dernier moment
la télé a été installé et à force de se
faire mousser le football est le sujet
de prédilection dans le dernier salon où
l'on cause
au départ on s'est dit bon et faire que
les gens on n'aura pas beaucoup d'hommes
durant le match tous deux femmes et est
en fait les femmes si c'est pour
regarder max et le grand bleu a déteint
sur un public inattendu
le mondial c'est la dernière coupe à la
mode les françaises se sont piqués au
jeu et aux joueurs laurent blanc thuram
alors attention si on gagne ça va friser
l'hystérie depuis le début de la coupe
du monde de nombreuses escroqueries ont
été décelés à la billetterie jusqu'à la
veille de la finale les supporteurs sont
victimes de tour opérateurs peu
scrupuleux et la fédération en compte
bien en tirer des enseignements pascal
golomer benoît gallerey jusqu'à la
semaine dernière il pensait bien avoir
touché le précieux sésame paris qui est
aujourd'hui la seule chose qu un petit
peu de valeur et puis une jolie
invitation une carpe heureux une carte
qui ne remplace pas le billet pour la
finale et le biais de mini core l'attend
toujours sur son entreprise spécialisée
dans les logiciels de jeux avaient
commandé 110 places pour ses meilleurs
clients européens auprès d'une agence
londonienne hôtels de luxe restaurants
transfert au stade
montant de la facture 1 millions de
francs mais le tour opérateur n'a jamais
livré les billets abusé dit-il par un
intermédiaire peu scrupuleux
l'image que les gens garderont en
mémoire c'est que la société avec toi
car tu n'as pas honorer cette invitation
ils ne veulent pas tellement savoir ce
qui s'est passé avant après pendant qui
est responsable
le fait est que la mi temps c'est nous
et donc le responsable au final ce nous
venons plus n'iront pas en finale
230 touristes américains australiens
brésiliens qui avaient acheté leur
voyage et leur place pour les trois
derniers matches auprès d'une agence de
la nouvelle orléans c'est moi hier ils
ont trouvé dans leur chambre d'hôtel un
simple courrier leur annonçant qu'il n'y
avait plus de billets pour demain ils
devront se contenter du match de ce soir
entre autres ma femme et moi nous avons
des procédures karam 2003 l'argent qui
avait scellé rêve des cartes ra une
escroquerie de plus sur le même modèle
que les précédentes des tours opérators
qui ont vendu des billets avant de les
acheter percevait de les trouver ensuite
sur le marché parallèle auprès des
différentes fédérations nationales de
football
nous connaissons les fautifs nous allons
faire nous mêmes également une enquête
disciplinaire à ce sujet mais n'oubliez
pas mesdames messieurs on n'arrivera
jamais à enlever la tricherie en
attendant les victimes devront se
contenter de main comme des centaines de
millions de supporters de regarder les
images à la télévision
dans les salons de l'elysée jacques
chirac a élevé doivent l'enjeu la
dignité de grand officier de la légion
d'honneur en présence de michel platini
joseph blatter président de la fifa joao
havelange président sortant dont que la
fédération internationale de football
l'occasion pour le chef de l'état d'
exprimer la fierté de la france d'aller
en finale
à n'en pas douter la coupe sera
française nous l'écoutons pour ma part
je parlerai de notre superbe équipe
tricolore pour la première fois dans
l'histoire du mondial
elle est en finale et elle met à notre
portée rêve que tous les français
attendent et et auquel il croit à toute
l'équipe de france je veux dire je suis
avec vous tous les français sont avec
vous et que demain soir la coupe du
monde soit la vôtre que demain soir la
coupe du monde soit française
j'en ai la conviction au tour au stade
de france avec aujourd'hui dans l'
annexe de sané les répétitions de ce
grand défilé yves saint laurent qui se
déroulera juste avant la finale trois
cent mannequins venus des cinq
continents évolueront sur la pelouse du
stade ce film est l jean-jacques le
garrec
il semblerait que ce soit la mode du
jour tout le monde porte sans fléchir
sur la tête les filles aujourd'hui n'ont
pas grand chose d'autre à ce mettre sur
le dos et pour cause le grand jour c'est
demain un défilé de mode en plein stade
l'idée est née de la rencontre entre
michel platini et pierre bergé pdg
d'yves saint laurent
aujourd'hui on répète les figures de
style 300 mancka faire évoluer sur une
centaine de mètres alentours on
travaille ça va nous donner cette
sensation que tout ça se déplace
d'une manière un petit peu magique est
complètement irréel
et c'est évidemment la slovaque adriana
mannequin mais aussi fiancée du joueur
christian karembeu qui symbolise le
mieux cette rencontre entre le sport et
la couture évidemment demain le plus
important ce sera un match
l'une est pour une fois que je foulerai
la pelouse du stade
je pense que je vais être égoïste je ne
pense fait qu'à moi
demain ils s'en rendent racontera son
histoire personnelle en 15 minutes 22
tableaux et si tu aimes de l'exotisme
pop art
quarante ans de création célébrée devant
des centaines de millions de
téléspectateurs
jamais un défilé de mode n'aura connu
pareille publicité
voilà ce que l'on pouvait dire sur cette
dernière journée avant la finale toute
la rédaction sera mobilisé deux mâts
pour vous rendre compte de cet événement
historique et une édition spéciale qu'il
y aura toute la nuit de dimanche à lundi
après la victoire espérée des bleus à
moi encore de football avec dans
quelques instants la rencontre au parc
des princes entre les pays bas et la
croatie
un match de classement pour la 3e place
du mondial
les départs en vacances il y avait du
monde sur les routes bison futé ne s'est
pas trompé la route vers le soleil est
bloquée au niveau d'orange dans le gard
à nîmes sur l'autoroute a9 trafic très
dense dans la région de grenoble vers
les alpes et en fin de journée toujours
des bouchons dans la vallée du rhône
nous retrouvons benoît gallerey au grand
jeu des prévisions de l'été 98
bison futé avait placé ce samedi en
deuxième position il avait vu juste
toute la journée on a compté en moyenne
60 km de bouchons dans la vallée du
rhône
dure journée pour les moteurs et pour
les nerfs des conducteurs pourquoi ils
ont ils auraient dit partir en décalé un
nul et c'est de nous partir en premier
ils ont peu après été d'attendre de
s'arrêter d'euros par club phare est lui
de repartir en chaleur
je plains les enfants les aiment
beaucoup les employés bébé et dans cette
course d'escargots il ne manquait plus
que les camions autorisés à rouler à
partir de la mi journée
beaucoup de routiers étrangers et un
réseau encore plus saturé ce n'est pas
tout à fait normal parce que l'ultra
vias ce n'est pas sécurisant bouchon
chaleurs d'été et dure et de faire c'est
un grand classique de cette transhumance
vers les bacs en est à 28 ans c'est pas
terrible non mais la voiture elle fume
mais c'est normal puisqu'il fait beau et
pour ceux que la poisse rend moins
philosophe la société d'autoroute a tout
prévu
attention les mains là que paris poussé
avec les paumes de main sur l'air de
service fait le plein de zen
cela s'appelle du tai-chi-chuan tu as un
effet de calme ont calmé les personnels
en fait de d'énergie qu'ils ont à dire
qu'on permet aux personnes de se
reconcentrer
parce qu'elle sent un signe dans le sol
ils peuvent se sentir beaucoup mieux et
lâcher un peu toute rétention de la
route s'enraciner dans le sol
aujourd'hui le lot commun des auto
stoppeurs routard est très en retard
aujourd'hui je serais presque aller plus
vite à pied puisque effectivement pour
parcourir 50 kilomètres j'ai mis à peu
près 5 heures si tu veux éviter les
ennuis l'espace et le samedi avait prévu
bison futé bien vu car pour rouler il
aura fallu attendre la fin de la journée
le port de marseille bloqué ce matin par
des marins pêcheurs pour protester
contre l'interdiction des filets
maillants dérivants cette interdiction
prendra effet en 2002 des chalutiers en
bloquer l'accès au bassin du puy l'eau
jusqu'au début de l'après midi
deux ferries en provenance de tous et
d'alger ont été déroutés vers toulon
dans les bouches-du-rhône rassemblements
des tricolores les militants du front
national réuni autour de leur leader
pour célébrer davantage leurs valeurs
nationalistes plutôt que les couleurs de
l'équipe de france
un langage très différentes de toute la
classe politique un contre-pied ou
soutien unanime des politiques michaël
darmon grégoire ausina si les partis
politiques sont à l'unisson avec
l'équipe de france à la fed et tricolore
du front national on préfère rester sur
la touche lorsqu'on demande un pronostic
pour france brésil
ici les tacles ne sont pas tendres pour
les footballeurs français
vraiment aidé brésilienne avec chez nous
on n'a pas trouvé onze joueurs français
d'origine française pour jouer à vals à
voir le nom des joueurs on se souvient
qu'ils sont pas français vous trouvez
des jeux sont pas français la vie dans
ces mini foire en scène du sud de la
france pratique d'autres le repli est
l'anti jeu face aux bleus tout en
utilisant à leur profit les symboles du
mondial je ne m'étonne pas que nos cas
certains n'ont que trois ou quatre
joueurs de nos départements d'outre-mer
où le sport est un élément capital soit
dans l'équipe de france ça ne choque pas
tous les cas personne parmi nous at on
dit avec ile de france des gens qui
viennent de tous les horizons et d'y
verser la france aucun plaisir
non pas du tout pas du tout parce que
cette fois ci en fassent faut pas
prendre les gens d'ailleurs sur son
terrain dans les bouches du rhône bruno
mégret s'entraîne pour son match futur
contre jean marie le pen et sur les
exploits de l'équipe de france il
choisit l'ironie que la france va gagner
puisque avec la coupe du monde c'est la
seule occasion où politiquement correct
on peut être patriote alors profitons-en
en pleine compétition de l'euro 96 jean
marie le pen avait critiqué les
footballeurs français qui selon lui ne
chantait pas la marseillaise
aujourd'hui le front national qui
prétend rassembler la france se montre
pourtant en décalage avec l'émotion qui
traverse tout le pays à quelques jours
du 14 juillet comme chaque année le
décret de grâce présidentielle qui sera
accordée à trois mille cinq cents
détenus
trois anciens ministres renvoyés devant
le tribunal correctionnel de paris pour
recel d'abus de confiance jacques barrot
bernard besson et pierre méhaignerie
aurait participé au système de
financement de culte de l'ancien cds
mais ils ne sont pas soupçonné
d'enrichissement personnel
le procès devrait avoir lieu en début
d'année prochaine à l'étranger climat de
tension en irlande du nord aujourd'hui
la confrontation entre les orangistes et
les forces de l'ordre s'est poursuivie
pour le septième jour consécutif alors
calendrier soir plusieurs personnes ont
été aperçues interpellé pardon en
possession d'explosifs apparemment ce
groupuscule opposés au processus de paix
préparé un attentat dans la capitale
britannique
jérôme bunny patrick desmulie encore des
barbelés contre la détermination des
orangistes
s'obstine à vouloir défilé dans le
quartier catholique de portes dorment
c'est un véritable branle-bas de combat
de l'armée britannique et de la police
pour faire en sorte que la marche
interdite n'est pas lieu mais cela ne
semble pas décourager les orangistes je
resterai aussi longtemps que nécessaire
jusqu'à ce qu'on m'autorise à défiler
chaque soir amène de nouveaux incidents
la nuit dernière vingt jeunes ont été
blessés par des balles en plastique
cette confrontation qui perdure
multiplie les risques de provocation par
des éléments extrémistes la police
d'aster vient de diffuser ces images
montrant un homme qui rentrent au ras du
sol avec une arme automatique
il va faire feu à plusieurs reprises
vers les forces de l'ordre provoquant la
panique autour de lui
des pourparlers secrets et indirects ont
lieu en ce moment même à quelques
kilomètres d'ici pour essayer d'éviter
le pire demain et après-demain au rendez
vous traditionnel des marches orangistes
et puis on a appris ce matin la
libération du français fabrice michel
entre détenus dans l'ex zaïre ce membre
de médecins du monde est arrivée à paris
aujourd'hui après deux mois de détention
à berlin plus d'un million de jeunes
pour assister à la love parade le plus
grand défilé au monde de musique techno
pour cette neuvième édition qui prône
l'amour et la paix plusieurs cortèges et
quarante sept camions chargés de haut
parleurs nivière l'air un carnaval de
rio à l'allemande
un mélange de bonheur collectif et de
plaisir solitaire où tout est permis ou
presque
la love parade c'est le corps en extase
qui prend le rythme de cette musique
répétitive et l'on vibre des pieds à la
tête
j'ai mis du gesvres ces trois mois et
c'est bon les meilleures places sont
autour des chars un grand prix sont
mieux que n'importe quel discothèque
une des mesures qui fait rêver
jack lang elle serait génial si on
réussit à paris si on réussit dans
beaucoup d'autres villes de france
on peut concevoir un mondial de la
techno les chars attire comme des
aimants cette foule chaque année plus
nombreuses
une pluie glaciale s'est mise à tomber
un moment de répit pour les oreilles qui
sifflent et comme après un bombardement
aujourd'hui la fête avec 700 mhz bac
techno comme si l'allemagne qu'ils ont
dessiné au sol avec leurs corps avaient
gagné la coupe du monde tu est en ouest
berlin souris mais la love parade a un
prix 300 tonnes de déchets qu'il faudra
ramasser demain personne ne s'en soucie
c'est bien la seule journée où les
allemands se laisse aller pour produire
un spectacle en ligne droite n'étaient
que 150 pour la parade de labour avant
la chute du mur de berlin l'été des
festivals avec le festival d'avignon
depuis gérard philipe personne n'avait
osé rejouer le cid et bien cette année
c'est un metteur en scène anglais qui a
décidé de s'attaquer au mythe avec cette
originalité c'est un jeune comédien noir
qui reprend le rôle du cdh caroline
laudrin jean moulin c'est un défi jouer
le cid en avignon 51 ans après gérard
philipe
ce rôle de jeune premier dans la pièce
de corneille williams n'a dylan n'avait
jamais osé y penser lui un noir à qui
ses professeurs de théâtre conseillait
plutôt les claquettes ou le saxophone
au bout d'un moment on passe cette
question ridicule
de couleur de peau bétail chromatique on
arrive à l'essentiel des choses dont
nous avons tous la poésie en touche la
beauté du verbe
en tout ce genre de choses qui traverse
les années je traverse le temps nous
partîmes 500 mais par un prompt renfort
nous nous vîmes e3000 petit résumé l
usage de ceux qui ont oublié leurs
classiques pour une affaire d'honneur
rendre ictu le père de celle qu'il aime
schimmel 2d et score il veut mourir part
au combat en revient couvert de gloire
montré du courage du ressentiment
si venger un soufflet méritent un
châtiment je vois seule voix tomber
l'éclat de la tempête quand le bras a
failli non avenue la tête qu'on nomme
pris ou non ce qui peut nous leva
sirgant celui-là il n'en est que le bras
le metteur en scène le mot chapeau un
anglais qui aime autant shakespeare que
corneille pour lui le site c'est
l'espagne en 1940 en pleine guerre
civile
l'histoire change de verre en vers et ça
je trouve magnifique et qui a pas
beaucoup de pièces avec un tel nombre de
selles dans le sens que ça ne traiterait
pas très puissante privé d'un pain et
voulait mais encore peu de dire mais
elle vit
pigeon
le décor est dépouillé le temps
résolument contemporain de quoi nous
faire oublier les alexandra et l'amour
dans tout cela
corneille n'avait pas voulu trancher et
c'est toujours aux spectateurs d'en
décider
le saxophone guy lafite est décédé
aujourd'hui à l'âge de 71 ans des suites
d'une leucémie originaire de
haute-garonne lafitte jazzman
autodidacte avait été l'un des piliers
de gym auquel il avait participé depuis
la création de ce rendez-vous du jazz
mondial guy lafitte
avec l'été en août 96 ses 50 ans de jazz
ainsi se termine ce journal je vous
rappelle les principaux titres à dublin
en irlande coup d'envoi du tour de
france avec le prologue remporté par le
britannique chris boardman en marge du
tour cette affaire d'anabolisants 400
flacons retrouvé en possession du
soigneur de richard virenque la veillée
d'armes pour les tricolores à
clairefontaine le rêve bleu de tout un
pays qui se prépare à 10 cet événement
historique heures
dans un instant la météo de laurent
romejko je vous remercie de votre
attention excellente fin de soirée sur
france 2